sortir les élèves radicalisés de nos
établissements scolaires c'était la
promesse du ministre de l'éducation
nationale Gabriel hatal quelques jours
après l'assassinat du professeur
Dominique Bernard à haras mi-octobre
pour autant sur les 1000 mineurs fichés
pour islamisme la plupart sont
actuellement scolarisés et plusieurs
dizaines d'entre eux représentent
potentiellement une menace selon
l'éducation nationale une source
d'inquiétude pour le personnel éducatif
un cassête pour le gouvernement
l'instruction obligatoire est en effet
inscrite dans la loi pour tous les
enfants âgés de à 16 ans révolu qu'il
soit français ou étranger domicilier sur
le territoire un élève radicalisé on en
fait quoi sur quelle base juridique
peut-on exclure de l'école un élève qui
passe ses journées sur des sites
salafistes les enseignants sont certes
tenus de signaler tout incident à la
hiérarchie mais à moins d'avoir la
preuve d'une préparation d'attentat
débouchant sur une poursuite judiciaire
déscolariser un élève est impossible au
total 183 élèves ont menacé des
enseignants on fait l'apologie du
terrorisme lors de l'hommage à Dominique
Bernard ils attendent aujourd'hui leur
conseil de discipline mais s'il n'y a
pas de poursuite judiciaire et de
mesures de détention provisoire l'élève
reste à l'école déplore le président
d'un syndicat enseignant c'était le cas
de l'assassin d'aras Mohamed mogoukov
fichers s est signalé au fichier des
signalements pour la prévention de la
radicalisation à caractère terroriste
les mineurs et jeunes majeurs
radicalisés et identifiés par le
ministère de la justice sont suivis par
des éducateurs de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse mais là encore
les moyens manquent les éducateurs sont
dépassés ils doivent gérer 50 gamins
chacun je n'ai pas de nouvelles de
certains élèves depuis plusieurs
semaines j'ai appris récemment que l'un
d'entre eux était en prison et qu'un
autre était parti en Syrie alors que
l'éducateur n'était pas au courant parmi
eux ils sont déjà 10 et tous mineurs
avoir été mis en examen en 2023 pour
projet terroriste rapporte le parquet
national
[Musique]
antiterroriste